[Music]
that's great Margaret hi I'm Bob
computers can be intimidating for
seniors like you and me that's why we're
committed to providing seniors the
skills they need so that computers won't
intimidate you
you'll intimidate them
[Music]
grandchildren they're a blessing in any
seniors life and now with social
networking sites you can stay in contact
anytime you like and feel comfortable
that they're gonna remember your face
for years after you die Google+ allows
you to place your friends in different
categories or circles depending on how
much you care for them you can also give
you grandchildren a low-ranking if you
feel they need to give you more
attention yeah let's keep this computer
screen open and in plain view Sarah well
hello and how's my granddaughter doing
look I'm using a means of communication
that is modern and that you can
understand yeah I didn't mean for you to
see that but hey if you draw me some
water for my feet
I'll think about moving you to a better
circle how's that sound
sorry again there are a lot of nice
people to meet out there in the digital
network hey you might even find better
grandchildren ones that really do enjoy
listening to your war stories it's easy
to meet them get out there and enjoy the
technological experience
[Music]